[Music]
hello and welcome to indie movie guide I
am Alicia and I cannot sing yeah yeah I
shouldn't give up my day job but um this
week in the theaters I can live
vicariously through Emma Stone and Ryan
Gosling and live out my fantasies of
being in a musical by watching lala land
and I'm gonna tell you all about that
film coming up soon but first let's
start off with a little psychosexual
drama
shall we in theaters and on
video-on-demand this week you can catch
a movie called Frank and Lola and I
encourage you to seek it out it stars
Michael Shannon and Imogen Poots and
it's all about a relationship that turns
very paranoid you really watch out for
me I'm not used to it I'll get used to
it every morning when I wake up first
thing I think of is you you fall in love
easily Frank
so Frank is a talented chef but even
then he's not quite sure that he's good
enough for Lola the flighty fashion
designer and that insecurity spills out
into something quite dark now this movie
is best when it looks at the complexity
of relationships particularly from the
male perspective it does go a little bit
out there with the plot but the person
that grounds at all is Michael Shannon I
cannot believe how good he is in every
single film I mean just think about this
year alone he's been in Midnight Special
he was in that small but important part
of loving nocturnal animals where who
probably get a Best Supporting Actor
nomination at the Oscars and I hope he
does and now Frank and Lola and that
plus the cinematography and the way that
it looks at relationships through this
psychological thriller lens is the
reason why you should try to see Frank
and Lola no man should be exposed
[Music]
are me you to another smaller film that
you should try to seek out if at all
possible is called sugar mountain this
is another twisted drama about two
brothers who decide to fake a missing
person in the mountains story so that
they can sell that story to the media
make some money pay off their debts and
also pay off this thug who's after them
who's played by Jason Momoa we need cash
the plot of sugar mountain moves at a
really great pace and the brothers get a
whole lot more trouble than they
bargained for when they go on this
venture and Jason Momoa gosh he uses his
huge physique in full force to be this
very scary thug which is exactly what
that role needed it's also shot
beautifully and very entertaining so try
to seek out sugar mountain if it is
playing at all near you this weekend if
not I am sure it's gonna be on video on
demand very soon Man Alive is decreasing
and now to the film that I might
possibly be addicted to because I've
seen it six times actually I'm pretty
sure that I am addicted to it I'm
talking about lala land and when you see
this movie if you know me at all you
will understand why I love it so much
because lala land is an ode to classic
musicals it's an ode to classic movies
it's about Los Angeles it's about
chasing your hopes and ambitions and
dreams also love and the choices we make
and how those choices affect you in the
future and it also styles my favorite
Emma Stone
yes you are maybe I'm not it's like a
pipe dream this is the dream
it's conflict and it's compromised it's
very very exciting
big words watch on this one or I should
do bigger words watching this one
possible Oscar nominations for Best
Picture the Best Lead Actress for Emma
Stone Best Lead Actor for Ryan Gosling
Best Director for Damien Chazelle best
production design best score best song
so many more it'll probably sweep most
of the awards this award season and it
definitely deserves - it's a bloody joy
to watch it looks beautiful it'll hit
you in the fields everyone can relate to
this it's got great songs and dance
numbers and have I convinced you yet if
not here is our modern day bogie and
Bacall Ryan Gosling and Emma Stone to
tell you more I love this movie so much
as someone who grew up watching classic
musicals and dreaming of moving to LA I
know you didn't just make it for me but
it feels like you did you're welcome
after doing this film with something you
had to be so out of your comfort zone
for do you feel more fearless in a way
about movies in general I had such an
incredible like deep experience doing it
because when you put so much of yourself
into something and you rehearse for so
long you you really give you know you
give it your all and I just fell in love
with that element of the of the process
I mean I would have thought it would be
hard to look indignant while wearing
yellow eighties pants but you pull that
off really well thank you what did you
relate to with the character of
Sebastian or was there something
particular that you loved about him I
loved the time in his life that you meet
him in the film because he's experienced
a lot of failure and rejection and he's
he's right on the cusp of becoming a
very angry bitter person he which is the
worst time to meet somebody a potential
love interest but that's that's the way
it happens in the
congratulations you nice jazz hands
so with lala land now in theaters my top
five looks like this my top best movies
it is moonlight mantis both the
la-la-land arrival nocturnal animals
sorry lion lion is still fantastic but
it just goes down a step or two and so
many more movies coming out towards the
end of the year so I'm sure that will
change once again and yeah I know I'm
gonna get a lot of comments like do I
you love Lola lens so much for it's not
your number one it's hard to explain but
I think I look at this as as the the
best made movies and I just thought
moonlight was something I'd never seen
before
and here's what I see for the top 10
contenders for the Best Picture nominees
arrival fences Jacky hacksaw red ship
they're ready to forgive Mel Gibson make
sure lala land lion loving moonlight
manchester by the sea and silence by
martin scorsese silence is the only one
on these that I haven't seen yet but it
is getting good files from the few
screenings that it had so far
to recap once again what you can see
this weekend check out lala land in
theatres if it's not playing near you
right now it will be expanding over the
next few weeks
also in theaters and on video on demand
make sure you catch Frank and Lola and
try to see Sugar Mountain in theaters
once again that'll probably be on video
on demand later on so don't fret if it's
not in your area just yet and that's the
end for another Fandango indie movie
guide let me know in the comments below
what you think of this week's movies
what you think of lala land whether I
pipe this movie up way too much probably
have but I don't care I'm gonna go see
it for a 7th time and I will see you
next week right but I'm just rambling
now so shut up Alisha